Okay, JP,
I've been procrastinating long enough.
I need to do something about privacy and
chopping the sharing.
Right now,
when you click on the my list screen,
you see every single shopping list.
And while it does show you who
owns each list, it still shows you
all of the lists that were created
even from strangers that you frankly,
don't care about.
Instead of this being a free for all.
I think the best idea would be to
implement some sort of sharing.
Here, let me show you what I've got.
My plan is that when you make a list,
only you can see and access that list.
So if I have my generic grocery
list here and I just made it.
Only I can actually see this.
But what I'll do is,
I'll add a little share button up here.
Clicking share opens up
a list of your friends.
Out of the hundreds or
thousands of users, or hopefully,
hundreds of thousands of users,
that they'll someday be.
You probably have a smaller circle
of friends that you actually want to
share shopping lists with.
So we'll store the data of who
you say that you often share
shopping lists with.
And then you could add additional
friends by clicking this
button down here.
And this will take you to
the add friend activity.
And this activity here would have
a list of all users of the app.
So you can scroll through the users and
find one that you want to
be your friend, say Kagure.
Press her name.
And that would add her to
the list of your friends.
Then, with any of these friends, you
can click the little plus icon here and
that will turn the sharing on.
So if this is Walter's screens and
he just clicked this,
then he'd be sharing with me.
Then when I open my version of the app,
I'd be able to see the new list
that Walter just shared with me.
>> That sounds good, Layla.
So I have another idea to add here.
What if we design the data structure
like this, let me show you my screen.
Here, you've got your list of users and
in each user is a list of push IDs for
the shopping list they own and
are shared on.
We can set them to some
dummy value like, true.
>> JP, so that does sound interesting
but I'm already seeing one problem.
The issue is,
how do you use the Firebase list
adapter with this kind of data.
The Firebase list adapter
will be passed to location.
So, I could pass them this user list
location that has all these children.
And then I'll try to
display all these children.
So I could display a list of
these push IDs pretty easily.
But ultimately, I'm going to try to be
using that populate view method to make
a list item that looks like this.
But I can't get this data here unless
I make some additional listeners, and
it just sounds like a lot of overhead.
>> Yeah, that's rough.
You could duplicate some of the data or
possibly use some Firebase built-in
filtering capabilities to only
grab the list you have access to.
I'll look into those but
honestly, right now I’m beat,
I'll check in tomorrow morning.
You should get some rest.
>> Nah, I've got some coffee.
So, I'll think about
it a little bit more.
It's just so
important to get the data right.
I don't think I should work on
anything else until the developer and
I have a plan.
>> If only there were some way to
know how users would use the app and
what kind of performance
constraints you need to deal with.
>> [LAUGH] Yeah.
Well, it's not like we
could see to the future.
>> I certainly can't.
[SOUND]
>> All right, good night.